hi I'm Pete LePage a developer advocate
at Google and I'm Cameron Pittman a
front-end course developer at Udacity
we're here to help you create websites
that look and feel great
no matter the device in this course
you'll be learning basic guidelines that
make sites look great
across the dozens of different devices
in use today so Pete you're the expert
what are websites like Google News doing
to look so good on every device that's a
great question
Google News uses two different
strategies a fully responsive version
for phones and tablets and for desktops
it uses a responsive layout that starts
at a minimum size that works well for
them but adds a layer of complexity and
extra work to keep things up to date
that's interesting now I know there are
a lot of different ways to accomplish
good responsive design
what about websites like skinny ties
yeah skinny ties is fully responsive
across all devices laptops and desktops
this is my preferred way of building
sites because it means no matter what
device the users on now or in the future
my sites probably gonna work well nice
yeah that makes a lot of sense great
then let's get started
cool